chào các
bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn các
cái thao tác về định dạng đoạn
văn chúng ta lưu ý như thế này khi chúng
ta tiến hành soạn thảo một cái văn bản
thì bao giờ chúng ta cũng nhập nội dung
văn bản vào trước sau đó chúng ta mới
tiến hành định dạng và trang trí văn bản
và như bên phải là cái phần mà chúng ta
sẽ nhập vào trước này còn như bên trái
là sau khi nhập xong chúng ta mới tiến
hành định giạ và trang trí rồi bây giờ
bắt đầu nha phần thứ nhất là phần định
dạng phần tiêu đề chúng ta chọn dòng
tiêu đề này trỏ vào phía bên trái khi
nào con trỏ chuột nó chất sang phải
chúng ta nhấp chuột thao tác đó là chọn
nguyên
dòng Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ định dạng chữ
hoa chúng ta vào thẻ home chúng ta chọn
change ke chúng ta chọn uper ke
định dạng in đậm chúng ta chọn B hoặc là
nhấn Ctrl
B định dạng màu sắc chúng ta chọn font
color và chọn
màu định dạng kích cỡ chúng ta chọn ph
siz và lưu ý đây là tiêu đề chúng ta
chọn là 16 hoặc
18 chúng ta đừng chọn những số lớn hơn
khi chúng ta in ra nó mất cân đối Nha và
16 18 là quy định của soạn thảo văn bản
hành chính đó rồi chúng ta
chọn tiếp tục chúng ta C giữa chúng ta
nhấp vào lệnh Center hoặc nhấn Ctrl
E rồi tiếp tục chúng ta định dạng cho
những cái đoạn văn ở phía dưới
phần định dạng thứ nhất là định dạng in
đậm in nghiêng in gạch chân cho các cái
cụng từ thì chúng ta quét chọn chúng ta
nhấp vào B hoặc nhấn Ctrl b để in đậm
eck hoặc nhấn Ctrl I để in nghiêng và
underline hoặc nhấn Ctrl U để gch in gch
chân đấy và có thể là chọn luôn color
màu
sắc tương tự cho những cụng từ khác
chúng ta có những thao tác định dạng
tương tự
đấy thao tác tiếp theo của định dạng các
đoạn văn đó là định dạng lề cho các đoạn
văn đấy và chúng ta Quan sát các đoạn
văn ở cái văn bản này là lệ nó như nhau
cả tức là lề trái nó giống nhau này lề
phải nó giống nhau này và khoảng cách
Thục vào tức là lề của dòng đầu tiên
trong đoạn nó giống nhau cho nên chúng
ta chọn các đoạn này một lúc chọng hết
và bây giờ tiến hành đặt lề thì chúng ta
phải bật cái thước lên mặc định thì nó
có bậc thước này nhưng trong một vài
trường hợp cái thước nó không được bật
thì chúng ta sẽ vào thẻ
view chúng ta chọn ruler để bật
thước chọn nếu nó bật thì chọn vào tắt
tắ Phả chọn vào nó bật được chưa rồi bây
giờ chúng ta tiếp tục
chúng ta sẽ đặt lề là lề của dòng đầu
tiên trong đoạn thì chúng ta trỏ vào
biểu tượng này biểu tượng này là first
Line in lệ của dòng đầu tiên trong đoạn
nhắp kéo qua phải để xác định lề Các bạn
thấy tất cả các đoạn đều có định dạng
giống nhau dòng đầu tiên đều Thục vào
nha Tiếp tục chúng ta có thể tiếp theo
là chúng ta chọn
là left inen lề trái chúng ta kéo qua
chúng ta thay đổi lệ này hoặc bên này
này r đ kéo qua thay đổi lên
à tiếp
tục chúng ta quan sát là một cái đoạn
văn khi gõ vào mặc định nó canh trái Tức
là bên trái nó thẳng Còn bên phải nó đều
nó dít Chắc bây giờ chúng ta muốn là
canh đều bên phải luôn thì chúng ta sẽ
vào thẻ home chúng ta chọn lệnh này
justify mình hoặc nhấn Ctrl g canh đều
đây đó là các cái thao tác đặt lề canh
lề cho đ văng thao tác tiếp theo là
chúng ta sẽ định dạng khoảng cách dòng
và khoảng cách đoạn bây giờ ví dụ này
chúng ta sẽ chọn và đoạn thứ hai nhập
đôi chuột nha nhấp đôi này đó chọn đoạn
văn để định dạng khoảng cách dòng và
khoảng cách đoạn thì chúng ta vào thẻ
home chọn lệnh Line and paragraph
spacing có nghĩa là khoảng cách dòng và
khoảng cách đoạn và từ 1 đến 3 đó là
khoảng cách dòng ví dụ th chọn là 1.5
này Đây đây khoảng cách dòng khoảng cách
dòng Nó Dảng ra 1.5 so với thông thường
và tiếp tục khoảng cách đoạn thì chúng
ta sẽ chọn Line spacing option chúng ta
có thể chọn Add để thêm vào
ờ cái khoảng tróng trước đoạn văn Add để
thêm vào khoảng tróng sau đoạn văn đây
before trước after là sau Tuy nhiên để
cho chúng ta tự xác định cái khoảng cách
đó là bao nhiêu thì chúng ta nên chọn là
LINE spacing option và đây before after
before ví dụ chúng ta chọn là 6pt after
chúng ta chọn 12pt 12pt là tương đương
với một dòng các bạn đâ thì trước là đây
khoảng cách này sau là khoảng cách này
đấy nha Rồi ok đây chúng ta đây trước
này khoảng cách trước này khoảng cách ph
Sau này tương tự cho những đoạn khác thì
chúng ta chọn đoạn chúng ta đặt khoảng
cách dòng ví dụ th đặt là 2 rồi Đặng đặt
khng cách đoạn là
66 trước 6 sau 6 ok đó nó Dảng ra tương
tự như vậy cho cái đoạn cuối cùng này
chọn đoạn chúng ta định dạng khoảng cách
dòng khoảng cách đoạn thì chúng ta vào
đây và có thể chúng ta cần chọn từ 1 đến
3 này chúng ta chọn luôn l spacing
option chúng ta chọn before after là 6
và 18
và đây l spacing là khoảng cách dòng
multiple là nhân lên
mấy chúng ta muốn nhân lên 2 thì chúng
ta gõ số 2 mà muốn nhân lên 3 thì gõ số
3 mà muốn nhân lên 1,8 thì gõ 1.8 vào
1.8 hoặc 1,8 thì tùy theo Windows quy
định nha các bạn gọ 1.8 mà nó lỗi thì
chúng ta sửa lại 1,8 hoặc ngược lại đây
thì đó là định dạng khoảng cách dòng và
khoảng cách Đán đây đoạn trên này chúng
ta chưa làm thì chọn đoạn văn rồi tiếp
tục định dáng thao tác tương tự l
spacing option Chọn khoảng cách dòng 68
khoảng cách như thế nào thì tùy mình
trình bày nhá
Đấy Ok Đấy và chúng ta có được cái thao
tác là định dạng đoạn đoạn
văn rồi nội dung phần định dạng động văn
là kết thúc và xin chào các bạn